ninety days Yonsei me the title alone is
terrifying yes but people are obsessed
with this show commemorating sure yeah
and it's easy to see why in ninety days
we're gonna be husband and wife people
say you know nineteen year old she's
just using you maybe she could be I have
a very hard time trusting Oliver with us
whether it is total guilty pleasure TV a
couple meets ones not a US citizen they
allegedly fall in love and then they
have 90 days to get married J just to
run through women he's very smooth if
Jesus came down from heaven right now
and said he cheated on me I wouldn't do
anything about it before we did the show
I used to think like what is wrong with
these people like who acts like that
knowing there's a camera in front of
them but when there's cameras around you
all the time like I kind of understand
how people snap on t v-- act crazy
what's in it for them one gets a green
card plus a reported one thousand bucks
an episode to air their relationship
drama Breanna can be a very jealous
person
she she's a friend of mine after five
seasons and twenty seven couples only
four relationships ended in divorce Russ
and Paola are still together after five
years plus they've got a baby on the way
their advice shows be patient that's
what you're going to need a lot of
patience it'll be in front you have to
communicate but all love and happiness
now we're getting there ya know so
romantic you know Wow 90-day fiance
returns Sunday on TLC
[Music]
[Applause]